yeah I can't do those tanks maybe back
maybe now I'm a little older I try it
now you know yeah how old years ago 36
good age man
we're the same old old old yeah we're
two old kids come on 14050 wow wow you
look good I'm gonna kiss every little
crease on that let me down I was so
excited and then you [ __ ] know it
no it's natural it's not that young you
won't know you're young you're young
cool yeah stupid stop the honest I feel
like you least wrinkles out any of us
here though yeah green moist
let's be real that's let sure Thanks you
wanna lose your shirt you got it you got
hairy with hair in it when the shirt
comes off yeah it's gross yeah guys in
New York bodies yeah we get the key
sauce
that's gross so me with Harriet tonight
all right we're on a show together
tonight we're Laugh Factory
laughs actor yeah oh [ __ ] have you ever
felt more disrespected on a podcast geez
I he believes nothing you say he's
accused you being gay like a hundred
times seven I mean it's like a little
bit it's what I [ __ ] deal with if I
love and welcome I mean I apologize
right I believe you
honestly I'm always telling you can I
formally apologize do be I mean clarify
yeah please do so first of all I'm sorry
yeah I gave you that impression yeah the
only thing I think is that I I think I
believe that you're a straight guy of
course how much but I do believe you
fought guys last night last night I'll
[ __ ] be a hundred percent hasta que
last night I was on Santa Monica
Boulevard and like I brought thought
with me pull my pants down a little bit
I have the thong and I'm showing people
as they're going to the intersection I'm
trying to wave people off the side the
road because I want to pee on some guys
back and I want to do that away peel
guys back and I got Yanis filming a
crispy kale it's something that I like
to check on you whatever you want got me
man specifically straight man that's
maybe coming home from work and I just
want to tell his family about it and I
wanted you to have like a little ladder
friend if you were wearing a crop top
then we are tenacious I'm telling you
awareness at least you're on the same
page wearing a Yankees watch it okay
okay root for the Yankees no I couldn't
agree more
absolutely man it's not exit or anything
like that staying at the hotel
almost stay in a hotel in West Hollywood
in my place I'm gonna sniff your feet
tonight yeah that's what's gonna happen
you hear a big kid we're gonna [ __ ]
wrestle baseball ain't no good here
who's next better yours or Jimmie
Johnson well me and my buddy my buddy -
we were talking like we're both I've
known since he was 14 and he was like
this is that I was like me to do stuff
don't [ __ ] say don't look at my
[ __ ] neck I like it's a sympathy case
talk oh it's tough working fine it's not
yeah it is I have a good neck god damn
it you have a slinky for that I do not
have a slinky for a neck look at you and
Jimmy John no no we don't have the same
thing I don't why do that the whole
femur
yeah yeah that was really cool big guy
just I mean just completely [ __ ] the
thing up so that's so funny I had to
watch it you know what I had to watch it
again because I got so distracted by how
big he missed it I had to watch it again
cuz I go that's the biggest dude I've
ever seen in my [ __ ] life
hey man hey where were you this weekend
how about I said where we come from I
was coming from Nashville no how was
this amazing sold-out show how's uh
how's our boy the club Brian it's great
I love him yep love break break and my
favorite people hung out yeah
did you go to dinner and lunch with him
no but it was so much he's the best yeah
weird it was it's it was the club was
great we I just Nashville is awesome it
was raining but yeah I sent Brendon the
weight the hair off I'll sentence here
like take a look at this this arm see
the Stewart sent me a picture of the
state is Tennant you're flying Southwest
though huh yeah the flight attendant was
so I know well it's the only direction
yeah I know we're direct flight aware
it's and I bought a first-class ticket
you know what that means
yeah a spend extra dollars a 283 right I
was 89 no it's all this a nine and I was
like expensive too
it cost me way cost me $300 more and you
can be accomplished get the Greyhound of
the skies here I know I gotta wait like
[ __ ] cows out front get on number
called
not man I like you and her so like are
you a 34 like that and I'm a 30 it's
like I'm a 33 mind if I
step in front of me all right let me go
dude does it matter just go Jen I'm
gonna send this to huh because I was so
impressed with her arm and then I asked
her she was like and the guy next to me
saw me take a picture he goes toot I
know look at her wrong I'm out and
before Brian so Brian senators picture
goes check out for sure this and this is
what I said to Brian so brian says me
that I go my flight attendant he goes
and he goes suck him off bro I go and
then I don't answer cuz I'm like annoyed
then I just get well did you
I got shut up Brendan and another
another one suck him off row in the
Armand oh my god that is incredible
that's a girl he's na sukham that is
sucked it that's impressive and her
whole body was like that she was in
great shape oh oh I thought it was a no
an attractive by the way attractive what
yeah great shape oh they're older like
my age maybe Lau yeah hey I'm not trying
to make fun in the least bit yeah she
has a very similar arms there's not a
little more muscle more much but like
similar don't think that I didn't say no
I thought to myself her hands are bigger
st. we have similar arms their hands are
way bigger dude
you shut up percent sure I am I'm
addressed although when I was at The
Comedy Store I was talking to a couple
of people and one of the women was very
attractive very Italian but unusually
tall but all girls 6 3 no 6 foot in heel
6 109 but yeah okay good then I promise
you there was nothing nothing masculine
I promise you as feminine as it gets
besides our journey technology's
incredible and I looked at my other
friend and I went I'm gonna ask you and
my friend selfie hey hold up if you have
to go hey I'm
just sums up a little thing in my gave
it away the goatee no it's so girly I
bet you I bet you she chooses everyone
yes I'm sure I don't know I'm sure she
fools everyone she was gorgeous and
feminine and and I didn't even want to
you know like I get it like sometimes
you're just a woman yeah I give it and
whatever that technology is they can ha
you know you yeah you she's a girl
100% it's a girl boy Leonardo DiCaprio
was actually on vacation with his
girlfriend and some of his friends this
past weekend and what ended up happening
was they were going through a very
specific route through the Caribbean and
they found out that there was actually a
man from another boat who got really
drunk the night before while he was at
work fell off of the boat and he was
just stranded in the middle of the ocean
for 11 hours swimming swimming they
thought that he was dead because the
chances of him being alive and found
were estimated to be like one in a
billion
so you were more likely to win the
lottery twice than to find this man
relief and then you're found by Leo and
holy [ __ ] who found him because he was
like you know what instead of continuing
on let's see if we can find this guy who
fell off his ship they end up finding
him and rescued him after they went
looking for him they went looking for
him in the area that they found out he
got a real phone what Leo fella he was
treading water for 11 hours and doctor
says said that he would have had maybe
like a couple more minutes until his
body would have given out he's
dehydrated he was starving and it wasn't
a white guy yes French man where
Brooklyn kids yeah he grew up in like
the you know upper s Park Slope Brooklyn
judge might woke dope yeah and I grew up
where I was like you know it's
blue-collar
Brooklyn yeah are they early Brooklyn
brothers born or raised in Bensonhurst
oh yeah yeah yeah that's out of the
family hey guys you ever go back there
visit her when I was a kid I used to go
back to see my great grandmother who was
- died in 98 or so I got good genetics
yeah you look good you are healthy keep
both you guys yes a lotta hell
here yeah a lot of you guys watch in New
York no nobody's really just read - I
got packets of dayquil in my pocket
right now
we're not healthy kit yeah we get
nervous the only one I know who doesn't
touch like bad food and his from Andrew
Schultz doesn't eat bread and sausage
bread yeah why are you Schultz is run in
New York City like it's North Korea yes
tells people he doesn't poop then that's
just what you have to be able yeah you
know Schultz you smart boy but you're
kidding right don't use our [ __ ] it's
marketing to that and he's our [ __ ] he's
really [ __ ] yeah no we're on the
Schultz where we are Schultz disciples
yeah but it's the thing as if Schultz
ever gets a little lippy I'll still
[ __ ] screw his head on yeah yeah
that's what he knows about us
horse boxing videos and I said all I got
to do is tickle your balls for three
seconds yeah
and that's it we'll be in a relationship
for two years you never know what [ __ ]
you being metaphorical right now you
know if that kid [ __ ] if people like
that want to pop off at me [ __ ]
corner them at the comments on somebody
or out here at the comments or tickle
their balls yeah and the next thing you
know they're bringing me home for
holidays and were in a gay relationship
out all over the world on his SkyMiles
cuz you sell tickets to me right now and
then he won't even [ __ ] realize what
happened and so it's three years and two
[ __ ] intricate adopted Asian baby he
said if either one of these guys start
talking [ __ ] he's gonna pop in their lap
so quick they're not gonna know what hit
them
absolutely hop in like it's Christmas
Tara all my friends like that do the
same [ __ ] as I do yeah I think that
might be broken for I'm gonna kick your
ass back Bobby I love a woman is
currently suing American Airlines
because last year there was a worker who
found her bag got her phone number from
the little tag and started texting her
before and during the flight he ended up
getting arrested as soon as they landed
in Chicago and she tried to stay silent
about the whole thing but she finally
got a lawyer and now they are suing
because he did this to a couple other
women it's interesting it's actually
it's interesting that that happens and
that and and it sucks that happen but
two weeks ago
I went to Best Buy and I bought
something for my TV and they used my
credit card and my information was saved
and the girl behind the register at Best
Buy started texting me about three hours
later telling me that she thought I was
hot and if I wanted to hang out and and
she was like I can come over I have your
address a lot she was you know she's
like a yeah she's like a young hot
enough girl but I was like it freaked me
out I was like wow if this was if I did
that to her right I'd be on IB unfuck
yet she a hot chick she was a hottie too
come on over don't I know my [ __ ]
textures like you have a hot brass and
she said no such as lighting up the
wrong tree the rolls are [ __ ] wat
their role in front so as wild but I
mean this is a creepy [ __ ] dude you
can't do that but I mean also it's like
there was no physical contact like what
is the lawyer gonna do it's Locke and a
girl give you her number on a by
gramming gonna give you a number on a
flight service but most of the fight
like this ready Southwest watch this and
she was taking it I look good I look
come on master long yes sure like the
neck yeah yeah yeah hey dude like that
neck don't say anything about your Tommy
Lee Jones net I have a nice neck I got a
good neck I have and that's good skin on
my neck looks like a slinky which is a
[ __ ] [ __ ] kind of hey yeah but
it's good I got a good neck I know
listen yeah I mean gave me her number as
I got I was so flattered I couldn't take
it and much younger all you denied her
the kid still has it what's aged will
never be no I was just impressed yeah I
was like yeah [ __ ] made my day they
didn't creep you out though did it no
keep creeped me out there's nothing a
woman could do to creep me out I had a
woman got drunk and sat next to me like
yeah the other guy got out and she was a
big gal older and drunk as [ __ ] I had
been drinking tomato juice yeah all
night tomato if I'm being honest the
only thing about a woman that's ever
really creeped me out is when they have
vaginas
Oh Chris Brian [ __ ] it they start to be
like I'm gonna call my lawyer I'm not
gay I'm just saying [ __ ] don't spread
that [ __ ] because I I [ __ ] have a
family man I know that you're being
super gay
using metaphors